llegó el momento de economía en france
24 nuestro periodista jorge hurtado
tiene toda la información porque buenas
noches y bienvenidos empezamos hablando
del viaje que hizo el presidente turco
reyerta y verdú and a emiratos árabes
unidos- porque su intención es buscar
cooperación económica así es y bueno
sobre todo es una de las principales
noticias en ese en ese continente
erdogán se reunió con el príncipe
heredero mohamed bin zayed al-nahyan
según la agencia estatal de noticias de
emiratos durante el encuentro se
firmaron 13 acuerdos entre ellos sobre
comercio industria salud ciencias
médicas transporte terrestre y marítimo
los emiratos árabes unidos y turquía
firmaron una declaración conjunta que da
inicio a las negociaciones para un
acuerdo bilateral de comercio e
inversión conocido como acuerdo integral
de asociación económica esta mejoría de
las relaciones diplomáticas se produce
en un momento en el que turquía enfrenta
una profunda crisis económica con una
inflación cerca del 50 por ciento y su
moneda en una devaluación histórica
mientras que emiratos árabes unidos
ejerce una política exterior más
conciliadora sus prioridades económicas
ambas naciones acordaron el mes pasado
un acuerdo de intercambio valorado en
unos cinco mil millones de
dólares en su moneda local y túnez
inició negociaciones con el fondo
monetario internacional que está pasando
bueno esto principalmente porque busca
ejecutar su presupuesto general de
estado túnez busque un nuevo crédito con
el organismo financiero el cuarto de la
última década porque el país enfrenta un
déficit público que ronda los 2600
millones de euros según la agencia
estatal tap el fondo realizará desde hoy
una visita virtual para definir las
reformas económicas y sociales para
acceder a este financiamiento pero entre
los requerimientos del fmi para dar el
préstamo es el consenso entre el
gobierno y los sindicatos la patronal y
la sociedad civil para alcanzar un
acuerdo que sea de alguna forma a largo
plazo túnez estima para 2022 un gasto
público de 6.600 millones de euros
destinados al salario de unos 700 mil
funcionarios públicos otros 1.100
millones en subvenciones de alimentos y
890 millones al subsidio de
hidrocarburos en julio pasado el
presidente de la pública caixa y
destituyó el primer ministro y suspendió
a la asamblea algo que sus detractores
tildan de un golpe de estado y ahora nos
vamos a europa del este porque las
tensiones geopolíticas están haciendo
que el precio del petróleo incremente
así es y para algunos analistas ya
prevén que en los próximos días el
precio internacional del petróleo
aumente a más de 100 dólares el barril
el precio del petróleo intermedio de
texas se robó y con un aumento del 2,5
por ciento y se situó en casi 95 dólares
el barril mientras que la otra
referencia el brent se situó en 95
98 dólares el barril en europa el gas
también mostró un aumento este lunes así
como el aluminio y el paladio 2
presionados por el temor de una invasión
rusa en ucrania
estimaciones del modelo shock de
bloomberg afirman que una subida del
petróleo hasta los 100 dólares para
finales de febrero elevaría la inflación
en aproximadamente medio punto
porcentual en eeuu y en europa para
mitad de año y pasamos a sudamérica
porque colombia anunció un crecimiento
económico que es histórico de qué se
trata bueno así lo anunció el presidente
iván duque desde bruselas según el
mandatario la economía colombiana avanzó
por encima del 10 por ciento interanual
en 2021 aunque hay que aclarar que esto
es parte del efecto rebote post pandemia
y se produce tras una contracción récord
del 68 % en 2020 y aunque colombia
lidere el crecimiento las proyecciones
en la región una de las mayores
preocupaciones el dato de inflación que
se mantiene casi en 7% interanual
impulsada por un alza del alimento que
golpea los bolsillos de los colombianos
y su capacidad de consumo escuchamos lo
que decía el presidente eduque and i'
want to express test from brazos to the
colombian people quiero expresar desde
bruselas para el pueblo colombiano que
en el año 2021 la economía colombiana
creció por encima del 10,2 por ciento y
esto quiere decir que hemos alcanzado el
mayor crecimiento económico de nuestra
historia republicana this means dawi
harris the high est economic growth en
el republicano steve jorge y cuáles son
los indicadores del día bueno iniciamos
con wall street que cerró en rojo por el
temor a una inversión rusa en ucrania
al pasar las horas ese mismo temor hizo
caer las bolsas europeas en este inicio
de la semana y en américa latina la
bolsa de brasil fue la única que mostró
un leve crecimiento del 0,29 por ciento
gracias jorge y gracias a ustedes por
sintonizarnos
[Música]